später werden gerade gehört bis in die
frühen morgenstunden gingen die
ermittlungen am tatort was gibt es jetzt
für erkenntnisse der nähe wir stehen
hier direkt vor der tiefgarageneinfahrt
wo in der letzten nach dieses
schreckliche unglück passiert ist wir
können jetzt hier sehen
es ist gar nicht so eine breite einfahrt
und der obdachlose lag wohl dort am
linken rand also es ist halt wie gesagt
eine sehr enge einfahrt und konnte
deswegen auch von dem auto mitgeschleift
werden und wurde dann 40 bis 60 meter in
die tiefgarage hinein geschleift und die
fahren selbst die pakte auf einem
anwohnerparkplatz was wohl dafür spricht
dass es eine anwohnerin ist sie
entfernte sich zuerst vom auto weil sie
den obdachlosen gar nicht bemerkt hatte
und kam dann erst zurück als das unglück
ihr schon von den vielen zeugen und
anwohnern bemerkt wurde als der
rettungswagen gerufen wurden und wir
konnten gerade auch mit zwei augenzeugen
die hier direkt im ersten stock des
hauses wohnen sprechen die uns mehr dazu
gesagt habe
ja also wir waren eigentlich schon im
bett und dann waren wir noch mal auf dem
balkon kurz draußen gucken und dann hat
ein mann also erst haben wir reifen
quietschen gehört und dann hat dein mann
geschrieben
die zieht den jetzt mit und dann haben
die reifen wieder entwischt und dann
sind wir da noch runter also haben erst
vom balkon gesehen dass er die polizei
ruft also die frau also die fahrerin war
gar nicht auffindbar als wir unten waren
das auto stand verlassen da und die frau
war wussten wir nicht wo sie es
und dann kam auch der krankenwagen
irgendwann und dann kam auch die frau
aus der garage irgendwo aus einer
hintertür
wir haben gar nicht erst wahrgenommen
das ist die fahrerin sein könnte mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren